[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be talking about how
California is the future we are sitting
down with Pete Lydon what's up Goods be
here thanks for coming on to the show
totally really appreciate it awesome you
came into my world like about last year
so I figured out about you okay I'm
through your daughter we had a I had a
little lunch and then your daughter was
like my dad hosted Vivienne Ming at his
event series and I was like what and
then that's how I realized that our
networks are interestingly connected I
need to start coming to your events and
I love your event series always about
the future and always with really epic
people solving some of humanity's most
pressing issues I love it so much so
that's okay so reinvent you know our six
years now yeah with reinvent my company
yeah yep so so so reinvent does a bunch
of different things as a media company
but one of them is these what's now San
Francisco and what's now New York yep
events yeah so tell us a bit about the
inspiration you were also at Wired
before that and yeah all this other
stuff so yeah unpack some of I guess the
history leading up to reinvent and now
what you're up to with reinvent okay
cool well so I came to California over
20 years ago early 90s to work at Wired
magazine and why are the reason I came
to wire it was it was talking about the
revolution the direct the digital
revolution is one of that really is the
first mainstream publication kind of
explaining what the hell is going on
with the computers and interconnected
computers the internet and so I was
there in the early days the original
crew one of the early guys not a founder
but in the kind of early days of that
and it kind of became smitten by the
place by the people by the kind of
network of crazy innovative folks that
wired was certainly in the middle of and
I've just been my life now for the last
over 20 years here and and one of the
things about wired was why I was really
about the future really wasn't it didn't
think of itself as a pure technology
magazine and thought of itself is and
still to this day thinks of itself is
really talking about the future and
talking about a future and all kinds of
things future science a future politics
culture society as well as it's driven
by a core technology piece and that's
kind of also been animating my vision
for the last 20 years and so I've done a
variety of things over those years which
if it's of interest where you go over
but of ultimately the last six years
it's been my own company called reinvent
which is a media company and have some
continuity with Wired it also is a
company that's really trying to connect
up what I would call the a team of kind
of top innovators which is where we have
some cook over lap here and getting them
to focus on kind of big challenges
complex problems things that are not
figured out yet and what we do is when
we bring them together in events we
begin to gather in roundtables we're
bringing I'd bring them in to kind of
similar situations of deep dive
interviews it's all around that
framework and so we have built audiences
and community and over time that it has
that was kind of interest and like I say
we share a lot of interest in that and
that's what reinvent is and so out of
that though we have sub projects one of
the big projects we have for the last
three years has been what's now San
Francisco and that's essentially a forum
here in San Francisco it's our kind of
invite-only thing but basically once
you're in you're in and you get to bring
in whoever you want to bring in but we
every month go to a different field in
the Bay Area the broader Bay Area
Silicon Valley and take some really
leading innovator in a space that can
explain what's happening in that space
with really interesting what's gonna
impact everybody else but also wrestles
with what are they wrestling with now
what are the questions they're wrestling
with what are the challenge they're
wrestling with what's their latest
thinking and they test out new ideas and
in that forum it's in front of this
cross-disciplinary now we're gonna
people that have come in from all these
other fields and you
really rich conversation about 90
minutes live streamed edited later and
put out into the world does that all
make sense to you I love our overlap
yeah yeah and not just only wanting to
bring together the a-team and also solve
some of these really pressing challenges
but also to want to inspire other people
to care about these major pressing
issues and I want to take us because
will will we'll get more into like the
what's and now cutting-edge stuff but
that also really relates to your past
because you have kind of been at the
cutting edge for a long time so in this
in this conversation we'll definitely be
talking about how California is the
future and it has been for a long time
yeah ever since the formation of the
internet and the formation of kind of
the Silicon Valley area this is it's
really exploded and you were you graphic
you gravitate towards this yeah totally
yeah well California
I mean it's Pacifica lens you want on
this but California has often been a
trendsetter it's always cut at the new
cultural trends the new social trends
the new technologies the you know it's
had a but also new political trends and
stuff and there's a bunch of reasons for
that I would say in general the
California literary since the gold rush
times it has attracted a an eclectic mix
of innovators entrepreneurs and kind of
just out-of-the-box thinkers from all
over the world and it just consistently
does that and over time you just create
this kind of crazy mix of folks that has
essentially built weirdly saved
traditions of innovation but it but it
just has just so consistently cut new
ground going forward in all these
different fields that after a while it's
it's something you got a really start
thinking about and I've actually spent a
lot of time thinking about this and
thinking about how do you start to apply
what happens here how does it affect the
rest of the country America's kids or
the world - yeah and this if you kind of
mentioned this kind of frame my frame
which ever an explorer in the last year
has been getting into explaining why
does that happen how does it happen
and by using a prism on looking at
California today how does that explain
where the country is gonna go in the
next 15 years or the world in the next
15 years and there's a bunch of ways to
talk about that if you want to go into
that but but yeah we're in a special
place right here and I am very bullish
on that sometimes people get put off by
that some time with Shawn it but it's it
but I think if you're really smart right
now you gotta tune in to what's really
happening area because it's it's it's
it's not just setting trends in some
respects I think of it again a beer
conversation is we're building the next
systems of the 21st century and those
systems are so different from the 20 our
21st century that we're building in a
system the 21st century and they're so
different from the 20th century that you
could almost think of it as building a
new almost civilization that will have
really long implications and I think the
more we think about that consciously and
are aware of the profundity of changes
that we're in the middle of and the kind
of long tail of what we do here how it
can impact the coming decades I think it
really it makes you think differently
about what we do every day here yes and
you also take this multidisciplinary
approach to your lens that you see this
with and I think that's a very crucial
pillar in the way that you are seeing
this and also communicating it to other
people so maybe maybe speak on the
multidisciplinary approach to
understanding exponential technology and
understanding its impact across all of
the different industries that it's
currently hitting I mean this valley has
had Google and Facebook and Apple just
explode throughout it and then we have
NASA Ames and we have similarity
University and we have all this
adventure money that isn't funding all
these Stanford and Berkeley are right
here and they're too
pron at university system sooth I mean
this is like this is a huge hub for for
innovating and especially for
Exponential's across these different
industries you've seen those as the lens
and you see them going to not only parts
of the US but parts of the world and
there are parts of the world that are
also influencing Silicon Valley there
are like some Shenzhen is definitely a
major hardware capital of the world
there's also lots of cultural trends
that are started in Europe and in other
places so but yeah go ahead and yeah
unpack more about like well well let's
go back to your first point which is to
my mind and there's nothing other people
think this too but really innovation
comes from essentially the cross
connecting between fields I mean if you
you know if someone's stuck in one field
you know you get a lot of smart people
in one particular field and they go deep
and they're experts and they know their
little space and there is some
incremental innovation that happens in
that case but most to me most innovation
happens from when you kind of mash up
different fields or you you really cross
connect different fields and and I'm not
alone in thinking that a lot of folks
think of that but I think we don't
really think we don't think deeply
enough about what's going on there and
what's happening is essentially
innovation is when you got one kind of
crew that's thinking one way and one
crew thinking another thing there's
enough overlap and enough kind of cross
connects that when you make those things
happen boom you push it out another way
that neither the fields alone was doing
but that there's a third thing going on
and so where you gotta look for
innovation is is in these kind of mashup
hubs of mashing up and
the big area at California is an America
in a way you know compared to other
countries in the world you know really
excels at this so if you take the whole
world like you Japan for example there's
innovation in a great innovative things
happening but it's very incremental
innovation because it's you know
homogeneous society of Japanese very
little immigration very little
cross-connect across cultures there's
smart folks and they know what they're
doing and they're tight but they're not
breakthrough innovations they're not
kind of opening up whole new fields
China to that extent is very homogenous
in terms of I mean there's a lot of
different variations within the Chinese
people but there's not super cross
connects across all races and cultures
and America is just specialized in that
for last 250 years it's been an
immigrant nation it's bring people from
all over it has very open policies of
bringing people in and there's very
acceptance of kind of the cauldron of
melting pot all that traditions that we
think that that makes for an innovative
culture in general but then when you
take this tilt to the country of people
kind of migrating west go west young man
and you know all the different things of
the open prairie in the frontier and
then the gold rush everybody's so
there's been this is good in the
Hollywood everything this whole pull now
it's that everyone coming to Silicon
Valley there's been this draw even
within a very innovative country that's
mashing up all kinds of ideas it didn't
tilts even more people into these kind
of California and then in California
it's really two hubs LA which is you
know polyglot of cultures and languages
and everything but Silicon Valley and
the Bay Area is even I would say one
more notch above LA right now in terms
of a magnet it's bringing a lot of tons
of young people all over the planet
people who really want are ambitious or
entrepreneurial or anybody want a little
piece of the action so it's just crazy
magnet that's happening here and when
you put all that together and kind of
stir and just let it happen and [ __ ]
happens and that's what's kind of
happening here the whole west coast of
you know there's a kind of a chill too
but I mean just Seattle's happening a
lot you know you talk about biotech you
San Diego I mean it there's a whole
media in LA I mean there's a whole
phalanx of things happening on the coast
but if you really want to go to Ground
Zero if you really want to be at the
epicenter of really what's roughing out
the next systems of the 24 century of
this
civilization this next thing really this
is the place to watch it doesn't mean
innovation is happening other places
that doesn't mean people can do all
kinds of cool stuff all over the place
but this is kind of a the uber place to
do it
two things okay the first thing is that
this sort of approach of seeing fields
and you David Eagleman recently told me
this as well he had published 120
academic papers and like six people had
read them and then he started neo
sensory new census for those that are
deaf that now they can hear through
vibration so they gave him new senses
same thing with their chest this month
like it should vest for vibration as
well we're featuring him on on Friday at
a live event and he's like now with this
entrepreneurship he's able to impact 130
million deaf people right and so that is
oh that's huge so there's a big
difference between you know being an
academia and tinkering as an absolute
subject-matter expert in that one narrow
field which we need we need people to
still do that but then we need them to
somehow enable somebody with fresh lens
mmm that also understands the
fundamentals to come in from the may be
decentralization movement or maybe the
nanotechnology movement or the biome and
whatever and now way these like you said
there's this massive breakthrough into
this new like child of the fields and so
I totally love that view and embody that
view and love the multidisciplinary lens
and I think it gives one of the richest
perspectives of understanding reality
possible and I think that's where you
and I buy not as as people that love
hosting smart evil and talk well because
there's a role of someone who can
connect those things or is smart enough
to at least dip into these various
fields and pull out enough of interest
and to help translate it I think it's
under appreciated a lot I mean you know
the journalism world that I originally
kind of grew up into in my early career
I was a journalist there was a little
lot of that going on where if you're a
journalist you tend to just move around
and talk to people and over time move to
different beats in the old days and move
to different regions of the country and
you know you could it was kind of
celebrated that you don't go deep into
one thing necessarily but you're kind of
this honey bee going all over the place
but of course that whole media feel got
destroyed and so but there's still this
need for this cross-pollination this
cross realization this kind of cross
connection now more than ever now more
than ever in many respects and so I do
feel it there is a role there that you
starting to see in podcasts you know you
got a podcast like this and a show like
you're doing but there's all kinds of
them now starting to break come together
and the lens is not oh I'm there you
know anthropology thing or blog others
that kind of work too but if it's if
there is a lot more sense that the world
is complex the world is really something
that we got to kind of worry about the
cross connects and the explaining so
there's a bunch of ways to talk about
that but it's the place to be right now
is between fields and cross connecting
fields rather than just be immersed in
one field or another yeah and then as
you there's I'm gonna get to that second
one that I want to get to but as you
slowly amass this multidisciplinary
understanding of the world and these
connections in these different fields it
becomes easier for you to link up people
I'm not here to do everything you're
actually more so here to help other
people find each other then so that you
can then be part of building different
futures by just linking people together
and having them go and birth these
children of ideas into the world so
there's that side of things which I'm so
happy that we were late on in this a
major pillar of this California being
the future there's so many buckets to go
and there are flowers to pollinate and
get pollen from and it's spread around
in Amazon and Microsoft we're up in
Seattle those are two major companies as
well that's another hub
like you were saying la Hollywood an
entertainment industry a lot of the
YouTube sensations going on there and
then the San Diego biotech learning
culture as well okay so so this is now
this being said you hit this point I
want to make sure we address it we still
give love to Chicago and New York London
all these other places around the world
as well you made it clear that diversity
of thought and culture these melting
pots is it a huge like pillar of
creativity and innovation and I was
trying to when we hosted Jordan Peterson
in our live event in February I was
really trying to point him in the
direction that it is actually you know
worth it to if people have maybe the
same sort of credentials or
intelligences let's say but one of them
is from this you know maybe you already
have a bunch of people that are from
Berkeley or from Stanford that are
working at your company it would be more
it might be more beneficial to the
bottom line to the ideas of the company
to everything that's going on for you to
fly in the person from somewhere in
Africa or South America or Southeast
Asia or wherever they're located on the
planet because they have a different
lens with which they see the world
mm-hmm and that means they have
different maybe philosophies different
ethics morality these different
principles that actually add so much
value to the idea and innovation and the
culture of the company now are there
like studies can we identify maybe
pinpoint some of these in terms of the
diversity leading to more innovation
yeah well after time I had I wouldn't be
able to just rattle them off without my
head but I would say that's totally the
case I would say the beauty of being in
the Barre right now is instead of having
to go out into the heartland or go down
to Argentina or something to find those
people is like they're coming here yeah
I mean that's kind of why I'm looking
here and have been for 20-some years is
just it's kind of self selecting now
there you could have met you could say
it's self selecting for innovative kind
of personality
entrepreneurial kind of characters risk
takers from these different places but
that being the case they're still
bringing the Argentinian perspective the
Brazilian particular you know the kind
of Minneapolis perspective they're kind
of there is this migration in and I'm
just always struck I've been here like I
say for 20-some years I used to run
wired I was the managing editor wired
and and so did a lot of hiring and I've
had a bunch of my own startups this
latest one for six years so if I'm kind
of hiring over my time and I'm always
struck when I put out a job thing if
it's an open kind of job just the crazy
backgrounds of people from all of the
world different languages cultures
countries continents who think nothing
of walking in and you know wanting to do
a job if so it's not as and I'm finding
that's particularly true in the last 10
years here 15 years with the Millennial
Generation you know it's kind of age now
it's getting to be about 38 to 21 kind
of period that generation is just coming
from all over the place I mean honestly
if I were a young person in that
category right you know 30 it's not
young in that way but my generation if
anyone in that kind of cohort if you had
to look around the planet right now do
you want to be in London do you want to
be in the Hong Kong if you want to now
there you know you can make a case maybe
for certain places get ahead of the
curve in China but but I would say if
there's one place you'd want to be you'd
come here and so that in fact has been
the calculus at most many people yes so
it's like shooting fish in a barrel one
you basically you know have an event or
invite people or go to a place and kind
of interview people it's it you're just
getting that diversity of opinion which
is why it's just kind of feeds on itself
Pete are you a globalist or a
nationalist
I am totally globalist and I'm really
bummed out about the kind of background
what's happening the backdrop of this
country which kind of does bring up this
corner to future thing a little bit
which is my bigger French I go there a
minute because about the politics that
or whether you guys go there because
there's a globe that the globalist
perspective here in the Bay Area and I
would say in California in general that
is being championed you couldn't see a
better you know there's places like New
York and others that have a globalist
perspective but
for Nia is hyper globalist not even a
smidgen nationalist in my opinion
there's kind of remnants of Trump kind
of people know you know middle of a
country Arab middle of the state or
something but in general hyper globalist
for good reason you know they've
experienced the diversity of globalism
they're tied in industries that are all
over the place they're in you know media
how it was all over the world you know
the technology is all over the world
they're getting along fine with all
these polyglot of cultures and languages
and everything coming up from all over
the world la is really superseded New
York is the kind of Ellis Island of the
world of the country now I mean so we
and we've now wipes our minority in this
state everything's fine it hasn't gone
to hell I mean we're living the future
it's kind of we are essentially where
America is heading over the next several
decades we're doing fine we're loving it
we're seeing the benefits of that the
innovation coming off that and I think
what Trump and kind of a lot of this
backlash to globalism is is essentially
a crew that's fearful of that conf you
hasn't really been exposed to that kind
of versity and so they're freaking out
and trying to do everything they can to
slow down that kind of move towards that
I would say inexorable move
maybe not inevitable but an extra will
move towards a more globalized
interconnected world thank you there you
go yeah that's great so we we talk we
talk about this quite a bit on the show
and this is gonna be an interesting way
to tie things in so the innovation
that's also occurring in China is
occurring without a polyglot of cultures
so we don't have this may be this
massive mixing pot of people from South
America and Europe and us and so it
cetera it seems to not be solely what's
what the faith when you say that about
the what's what the faith was it there
wasn't any intention for yeah I know you
know no intention for face because
you're a nationalist I haven't thought
of nationalist stop it stop with the
labels in general like let people be
individuals
so go ahead finished stop with the
labels off
just public service announcement enough
with the labels let people be
individuals okay back to the back to the
show all right so so now this is there's
this idea that okay in the u.s. we have
mixing pot we have lots of innovation
that's happening in in at least like we
were talking about in the Bay Area and
whatnot and then China's had a
significant amount of innovation without
a mixing pot which has also been
interesting to analyze and the I guess
first of all what do you what's your
take on that
well IIIi don't know one of my pieces of
my background is that was a foreign
correspondent for a while before I got
into the technology world I was a
foreign correspondent in Asia
I spent no about this party I was based
out there for several years in fact I
was in China way back in the Tiananmen
Square era in fact a month after
Tiananmen Square I wasn't in Beijing for
that but I was in too bad actually under
martial law in fact I was in I went in
through Hong Kong I spent a lot of time
in Chengdu and ultimately got into Tibet
under martial law I was spent time in a
Chinese jail there's a bunch of because
there's a huge crackdown I know a little
something about sorry that's a little
bit let me finish this boy we can get to
that so I've kind of spent some time up
I spent a lot of time in Japan I spent I
was actually based in South Korea
actually in that period late eighties
early 90s and so this isn't just talking
out of my hat a little bit I would say
that Asian innovation and including
Chinese innovation is not the same as
what we see here in kind of California
era you know kind of California or
American broadly speaking innovation
teach us about the difference yeah well
I would say and it has to do a little
bit with that lack of diversity they're
extremely good at incremental innovation
they're really good at focusing
resources whether it was the Japanese
economy and the government in the
the 90s or whether the South Korean
trying to like pump up new industries or
get behind Hyundai Motor's or Samsung to
kind of grow them into the global
companies they were they're really good
at amassing collective resources through
government and kind of focus they can
they're really good at kind of iterating
and making better and better mentor in
that space but they're not really good
at opening up all new industries trying
completely new fields like breaks
through kind of knew they wouldn't they
weren't coming up with you know the next
a Facebook or Twitter stuff they kind of
do tend to this day kind of follow on
patterns that have been kind of broken
through often in America that's all my
brother actual property and then and
there's a little that also a lot of the
best innovators that are really break
them invest ground in China in terms are
coming out of United States kind of
schooling and stuff that's not it's not
to say over time they might not of the
top sell nature science papers are being
written in China though it was just very
interesting true but again it's not the
stuff that's gonna kind of take the
world by storm it's not gonna open up a
completely new field it's really useful
when you want to put a lot of energy
let's say you know investments in solar
cells and refining that process to get
that to the point where it really
breakthrough but did they come up with
the original idea of a solar cell or did
they really they haven't really done
that kind of thing yet now they could be
getting there and that's they've you
know they're getting to be a
sophisticated economy and they have
their own kind of internal resources I
would argue though that two things they
don't have the diversity of back of
coming together and people are not going
to streaming over to China the way
they're coming to Stanford and Berkeley
that kind of thing and also I mean I do
believe an open media press and open
conference you know society that you can
kind of freely think and talk the way
you want I really do believe over time
that does kind of constrain the the
level of innovation you can do now you
know you can debate that and other
people might say differently but I do
think there's some limits on how
fundamental the reinvention was going to
come out of China I think
again my company covering that I think
if you're gonna really look for the real
breakthroughs on how do we really
reinvent or reorganize the systems going
forward it's not gonna be a Chinese
version it's gonna be I would say a
Californian version yes and so her prior
to getting to the California future
conversation that we were going into
let's go to the Chinese jail story ah
okay well well it kind of shows you a
little bit about China so I was a
westerner looking for Newsweek at the
time I was based in South Korea and when
Tiananmen Square happened and you know
for people who don't know the basics
there it was you know young people in
China coming together in Beijing to
demand certain openness of new I
franking and speaking and ideas and
democracy and the government just came
in and absolutely you know what tanks
and everything else and you know just
mowed it down and it stifled it and what
year this is 1989 and it was a horrific
crackdown and a lot of the Western media
that was already in China watched it and
we and people at that time were like you
know really caught up in it and a lot of
the country then was locked into martial
law and so I was the younger Kathleen
martial law martial law means the you
know essentially the government suspends
what rights you did have and again in
China was limited at that time compared
to what the rights we have here and
literally there's military folks on many
kind of street corners and and they have
an extraordinary ability to kind of
crack down on people gathering or
anything that's suspicious or anything
that would disturb the peace because
they're worried about this Tiananmen
Square getting into other parts of
country to other cities as in your
United States law privilege or yeah
worse was then voided yeah well for the
Chinese it martial law for the Chinese
but as a foreigner and as a visitor it
was also limiting what I could do and so
martial law tries to give you rights in
other countries no no no the martial law
that the Chinese were imposing was
essentially saying
for example putting curfews you couldn't
be out on the streets after a certain
amount of time Suzi Marshall abide China
on the Chinese people yes and I was
essentially outside the country when the
Tiananmen Square happened but it was a
journalist so I came in as under the
cover of being a teacher a young
traveler rather than a journalist
because it's the only way I could have
gone and they were not gonna let any
journalist said yeah and I was able I
was actually came in with my girlfriend
at the time I was later and now my wife
but we we came into the country and but
I was there to try to pick up what was
going on the rest of the country and so
I was kind of going route of inner China
not because Newsweek in other places had
Beijing in other places covered in Hong
Kong and she knew that I already think
dude I got there and then I basically
when she got into Tibet which was really
isolated and a big crackdown up there
and I was able to when I was there as
supposedly a teacher just traveller with
my Chinese handlers they wouldn't let me
go anywhere without a translator who's
really keeping an eye on me yeah that I
happened to be in an environment that I
saw a outside the palace of Dalai Lama
honestly it was a crowd of Tibetans who
were coming together which was making
the Chinese nervous and in the middle of
this group of you know probably 500
Tibetans
a small group of Buddhist nuns started
doing some chance to actually condemn
the Chinese for what they were doing Wow
and I was able to kind of in the case
that was started to happen in the police
started to go in there to try to break
this up and I was able to get away from
my handler jumped a fence went there in
the chaos got some shots of it and they
saw me take the photos but in the chaos
I was able to get my film canister this
is pre digital with the film canister
yeah get it out get it to my what my
girlfriend who crouched it literally in
the confusion she could no one could see
her do that and I put a different
canister in and we refused it and so
when they inevitably came to get me
because they saw me doing
hop the fence I have to Fanta the whole
thing and they saw that oh my god I
heard camera they arrested me and I was
taken into the Chinese jail system and
but what I did which was which is but it
was kind of creepy was really under the
this palace of the Dalai Lama that had
been built centuries before and it kind
of went to like the more okay jail but
very there was a guy there was a guy
interrogating me to kind of figure out
what's going on but what I did to kind
of confuse the whole thing was as soon
as they brought me in in the confusion
of kind of getting me going I said look
at I know you you want this film and so
I'm gonna give you the film and I opened
the canister and I pulled the film out
and exposed it but no one would ever
know was on that even though I knew it
was a fake one is so brilliant they
didn't know it was actually not that
because they were mad because it
couldn't prove it yeah so they were
furious at me and so but they so they
put me I did have to spend some time
there and but I'm ultimately that I got
out how long do you spend there do you
know what meanwhile my girlfriend by the
way when they took me in she went to the
hotel room developed and no it didn't
develop it but actually in it had a
false kind of ceiling you know how those
kind of things happen sometimes you can
lift the ceiling up and she hit it up in
the in there and because they didn't
because they did they did go to the room
to see whether something happened and
now I see why you guys have been
together when they watch this show so we
gotta be careful oh well I was worried
exhales worried about it thinks about
this was a long time ago but yeah the
point is that's a side story but it was
a great it was a good story yeah but I
but stories like this that also needs to
be highlighted in the world they're so
fast well you know Chinese come a long
way from that time for sure but it's
still you know the Communist Party is in
charge and they you know jail people all
the time and they shut people up all the
time and they won't let foreigners you
know do what I mean you know we forget
about that piece of China it's not gone
it's not like yeah I mean we're bad
enough here with
in my opinion Trump and the crew that's
coming into power here but nothing like
the Chinese and we forget about that so
what do you think about innovation think
about trying to innovate in an
environment like that where the police
can grab your employee in and you can't
take a picture of a thing that's
obviously happening in front of you
that's a different world of innovation
then you know all the crazy [ __ ] you can
do here and without having to worry
about it's been a time in a jail for you
know capturing the truth now oh who
knows in some Trumpy and future we might
actually get there so so so okay I would
love to learn more about your that story
and everything that's so interesting
hopefully on another time that when we
sit down there there's still so much
more to unpack so okay so so you started
unpacking this sort of in in the United
States we we do have like a private
prison system and it's kind of gross and
it's causing recidivism and it doesn't
actually rehabilitate people there's all
the stuff and yeah that's the purpose of
a private prison system to rehabilitate
people they want to send people out
commit more crime and send them back in
it's a multi-billion dollar business yes
and we got a long way to go to be able
to actually work on molding people's
minds to be less criminal and work on
that and also not criminalize things
like marijuana which is such a large
percentage of incarceration over half
last time I checked ok so then but in
China we have this crazy you like oh
well there's actually some authoritarian
top-down regime which will literally
police state you into jail for being
against it so that's also not okay
there's other places on the planet that
will actually just murder you for
thinking differently than them so we are
very grateful in the United States to
have what we have even though the person
that's in charge right now as the
president um you disagree with them
anyway so okay let's unpack the
disagreement so over the last you wrote
about this in the in the California is
the future medium series which we've
linked in the bio go check it out link
in the bio
okay so you you wrote about this at the
beginning of 2017 and then several times
since then you've been writing about
this that this is kind of the last it's
it's it's an economic transition that's
happening it's an ideological transition
and what that comes this sort of last
breath of yeah III yeah I'd frame me
this way is like you really sit back and
what's going on in our era here were
we're watching a fundamental transition
between two historical eras that there
was essentially in and in the
Enlightenment world that started back
you know in the founding fathers days
here but you know the days in Europe you
when Europe was kind of damn it we're
talking may 16th century 17th century 15
you know I would say me in the 18th
century so 1700s late 1600s and 1700s
there was essentially that's explosion
of new knowledge around the
Enlightenment the birth of kind of
representative democracy the early
Industrial Revolution you know discovery
of carbon energy you know all the things
that essentially have created at a
financial capitalism the flow of money I
mean we literally created this
civilization a Western civilization that
kind of came to birth in that period
which came to the United States and the
founding fathers part of that
enlightenment thing created from wool
cloth the way we organize our you know
government bicameral House of
Representatives all that stuff that
system has been chugging along and
building the Industrial Age he's
building the carbon energies kept me
building you know we kept electing
people and we've had this crazy you know
cresting in the 20th century there but
that system I would argue is starting to
really come to an end and that there's a
21st century system that will go for
centuries further I would say ok exactly
that is a digital civilization totally
different foundation that's a global
civil
that's got to be a globally
interconnected planet thing not these
little nation-states that we organized
you know 250 300 years ago but now we
got a globally integrated planetary
systems we got a climate change crisis
has to be a sustainable system we got to
get off you know fossil fuels also
there's a fundamentally different
systems that have to be created here and
so what we're living through in my life
has kind of been watching the tail end
of that old thing coming down and get
worse and worse and different more and
more difficult and the new thing get
birth you know from Wired magazine days
and others you know watching this new
things start taking off we're in the
middle of this transition and what Trump
and the kind I would say conservative
Republican backlash in the United States
but also it's being seen him
Briggs it European backlash the
right-wing and in Europe is doing it
something is they're horrified by this
and scared to death about this next
thing which is global and diverse and
all this stuff we know and many of them
also are rooted in these old industries
of like you know I'm in work in the
oilfield I'm with from Texas kind of guy
and they're doing everything they can to
slow down that next thing and to stop
this kind of old things kind of fall
into pieces and it's in that way well
what and Trump is just the extreme
last-gasp of that thing and we're
watching it so it's not like Trump is
leading us to a new thing and it's gonna
be the next thing for the whole rest of
the century and he's got a bunch of new
ideas how to go forward it's completely
he's a mess he's this kind of spasm of
ideas reacting against this next system
now unfortunately the next system isn't
fully developed to the point we're like
oh awesome that's what we want to do and
it's so much better than this whole
thing but I would so that's where you
get in this California the future thing
is if you had to go to one place in a
planet right now where that is the most
developed system where you really want
to see where are these technologies more
fully to adapted where is that globally
connected diverse crew working together
in ways where is the most sustainable
thing with the most ambitious agenda how
is this new life around biotech and
genetic engineering and everything else
getting worked out where to autonomously
Ackles work and how does AI work with
the humans and who augments what and
that thing is happening here
more than any other place in the world
and that the politics around that have
been adjusting for the last 15 years or
so to kind of accommodate that new way
of doing things and if you want to look
at where the country is going and where
the world could soon go it's happening
in California that's what the California
is for future series is in medium long
in-depth articles that lay this all out
give all the data I give all the kind of
things
now one short version to explain that is
California is a totally blue state now
super blue it's there isn't a Republican
considered a let alone a conservative
left standing there's all statewide
offices are held by Democrats
super majorities all this guy stuff is
monoculture recently you could call it
that but what I'm saying is the reason
that's happened is the craziness of that
Republican right wing conservative thing
which was denying the future was denying
climate change was all these crazy ideas
that are just so ridiculous it's an
interesting teal back Trump but he's
also libertarian and futuristic right
yeah he's let's not go into him I think
he's an oddball guy in that they're a
couple people that sort of believe in
that
like in that ballpark of like yeah
Batarian values they support yeah but
they're also media turistic it's kind of
interesting also true but the vast
majority of beer in California in
general and the tech leaders and you
know all these guys they're basically
much more I would say progressive
timorous know the pair of Democrats in
the old school not they're not that old
school thing there's a new thing going
here that the closest thing is it kind
of progressive Democrat which is why the
state is up and down it's a crazy
progressive space you know legalizing
marijuana I don't all the stuff we know
Gavin Newsom is a total tech nerd dude
is gonna be the governor that thing is
clutch closer to where the country and
the world needs to go than the Trump you
know kind of thing that's going on in
Washington right now and so and I would
even go down so far as to say there's
you can literally calibrate it to a 15
year time delay that one Reagan became
governor of California to start the
conservative thing 15 years later he was
the president United States and so you
know people say oh wait California's
always a kind of goofy
thing now what it used to be totally red
it was the birth of the conservative
movement he used to be you know all this
stuff California is the future of
whatever that next thing is
it was the future of conservatism for a
while and then the country went
conservative now it's the future I would
say blue state progressivism and I think
it's gonna come and it is coming fast
didn't think people think it's gonna
come to the country so anyhow that's the
kind of theory there and if you want you
know there's ways to read that and you'd
see it there's a lot of data on this is
all the demographic changes we've been
experiencing here for the last 20 years
is happening on time delay the United
States yeah cetera et cetera you can
just go through the whole thing
and so that is kind of the premise here
but it's an inspiring and I think
hopeful scenario which is like it's not
like there's no solutions it's not like
the politics is hopeless it's not like
we don't have any idea where to go but I
think the beginnings of that space are
already alive and well here and they're
actually growing now have we solve
homelessness now have we you know
there's a lot of stuff it's challenging
but that doesn't mean we're gonna look
to solve that I would say it I'd rather
be looking here and then looking at
Texas or you know Indiana or for that
you know other places in the world I
just think there's a lot of this is
where we're roughing out that next
system and you should pay attention
ironing out the kinks of civilization
and building the future well I mean
quick thought about what we just said
you seem to have all of the marbles
pushed in the direction of California
being the future and I tend to agree
with you about California being the
future in many ways one one part of the
marbles that I thought was that I
thought was interesting a lot of my last
couple years has been not only in
science communication but also in free
thinking that I listen to a lot of
people's perspectives across all
different types of political thought and
there has been a sort of growing
ideology about how about how it's
potentially true that the United States
has especially areas like California
have made a very strong
push in the direction of doing things
like using psychedelics and
understanding the whole like we are one
mentality and that they want to push
towards global is globalization
globalism really quickly and then
there's potentially other places in the
world that leg behind a little bit in
that sense they haven't used this many
psychedelics that aren't as
understanding of that we are one
mentality that are still waiting for the
United States to potentially drop its
walls down a little bit just so that
other people can take advantage of the
United States and that's where this
whole idea of this kind of like national
short-term nationalistic principle comes
into play on their argument in favor of
the long-term globalism what do you
think about that wait to shoot what is
it meaning the short term - art short
term nationalism in with the Trump thing
you mean put the walls up yeah I think
it's a disaster so it it's not about
like short term nationalism putting the
walls up like the actual wall Mexico and
stuff like that it's more about that the
United States staying in control as a
political leader
oh it's and and and and saying things
like the United States is going to stand
firm on some of its nationalistic
principles of regarding trade and just
geo-economics in general and then this
short term nationalism will then enable
the units to sustain more as a global
ear because other places in the world
might not be so so inclined towards the
we are one mentality quite yet in the
globalism and tell you quite yeah who
knows maybe they are even more so ready
than the United States is maybe this is
completely a wash but it's just taking
in this perspective in this ideology as
one that is a potential is interesting
to me yeah well it could be that black
sheep in the bay area the bay area is in
fact a monoculture the bay area is in
fact completely infiltrated with
identity politics yeah and it's just the
total truth of the matter is that when
you when you look at things from a more
of a multidisciplinary geo economic
perspective the United States stinks at
the frontier as a geopolitical idiot
leader at the most crucial time that
there ever has been to be a geopolitical
leader because of artificial
intelligence biotechnology
nanotechnology cryptic
see a blockchain technology all these
things are proliferating space
technology across the earth and if the
United States loses its geopolitical
leadership by by going like ah we're
good we're all psychedelic doubt its
shell let's all work together as a
planet but then all of a sudden that's
the perfect time for all the exponential
technologies and nations to come into
the u.s. and to be like thank you for
putting everything to the side and
letting us do that so I'm not saying yes
I'm not hearing people I'm just ya know
I keep in this sense that's interesting
well yeah because I also I'll kind of
one-up you on that a little bit in terms
of my own singing around this is and
this you know could be taken the wrong
way so I don't want people to take this
the wrong way but there's a side of me
they're thinking if you really take the
big picture maybe Trump is a good thing
that's some level from a global long
term perspective in that there was a
American hegemony thing after the Cold
War ended you know that without Russia
and all the stuff you know the American
kind of in the 90s actually when wired
was kind of going crazy and the Congress
booming and you know things were
happening into the early part of the
century here there was a vision of the
world is kind of with this one
superpower the United States kind of
driving things and I would say Obama's
vision was kind of building on that I
was a more benign idea wasn't gonna use
abuse that of Germany but I was trying
to think hey America needs to lead the
world into the sustainable global future
and and actually I was part of the
there's a whole other political thing
I've done with with Obama's campaign and
that kind of stuff and but that's a
different story but I was essentially
shared and generally that idea to the
Trump backlash to that was like at first
I was horrified by it but the more I've
been thinking about it's like well maybe
we needed an accelerated takedown of
that old thing whether it's the old
thing of you know the old you know
systems of health care and you know
bureaucracy and old government things in
this country or whether it's
Mobley at hegemonic United States
military running everything and being
the biggest 800-pound gorilla and
everything maybe there is a way that we
want to open more space up for other
people we want to open space up for more
regions we want to kind of lower the
kind of influence of the United States
at some in some ways around the world
and but mostly clear by dismantling the
old thing
maybe we're clearing space for a new
thing that post Trump Trump isn't gonna
leave the new thing is I never created a
bonus body in terms of real envisioning
the next systems but frankly weirdly
driving down some of these old systems
into the ground which is what he's kind
of doing maybe opens up space even you
know maybe we need a post NATO thing
maybe we need a kind of a different way
of thinking of Social Security and
Medicare and you know maybe there is a
kind of a 21st century versions of these
things that he's not envisioning in that
kind of way but he's kind of a vehicle
to kind of help dismantle the old thing
and accelerate its kind of transition to
something new and that kind of is
interesting way to think about it and it
may be closer to what you're saying and
and I kind of feel it's kind of
counterintuitive a little bit and people
freak-outs know for example I'm now of
the opinion that you know if we would
have had Hillary as a president Hillary
Clinton it would have been more the same
she didn't have the transformational
side to her she didn't kind of wasn't
gonna take us to the next level now she
wouldn't done all the dumbass stuff that
he's doing but that's what I'm saying
but maybe but she would have gotten us
to the next thing either so the question
is if we're really thinking
transformation if you really turn about
a fundamental reinvention if you're
really looking at our world post you
know into climate change digital global
sustainable that has to happen maybe we
need to start to get more radical and we
need to really start swinging bigger and
maybe whatever comes after Trump is
gonna do that yeah I'm glad that you
possess this open mind yeah it's it's
it's difficult to be able to calculate
all the variables and all the
disciplines that are going into these
nuanced thoughts but just the fact that
we are being so open-minded about the
conversation is fantastic
okay couple a couple quick thoughts I
really appreciate your the
for the globalism just because whenever
you see photos of earth from moon or you
see photos of Earth from from the
satellites that have went out super far
away and you just see the pale blue dot
you realize that everybody that's ever
lived and died has lived and died right
there on that little blue dot that has
built this world that we have and so the
idea of we are one we don't need to see
an alien race before we realize that we
are of the same tribe on earth so it
might take a little while and however we
get there I hope it doesn't have
suffering and it doesn't have lots of
violence along the way to get there so
let's get there together quick
okay last couple questions on the way
out okay what do you think about this do
you think we're alone in these cosmos me
yeah no no no no I really think I think
there's definitely other intelligences
out there I have a total oh I mean I'm a
big science-fiction fan I read a ton of
science fiction I watch a lot of science
fiction I think I'm really getting into
the expanse right now I don't know if
you know that whole that whole series
that I'm doing right now love reading a
ton of science fiction but in just
generally my worldview my way the cosmos
works the way you know biology will
evolve from kind of life evolves in
certain kind of just situations and all
the earth-like planets out there I'm
convinced that life is more common than
we think and then a lot of people think
and that actually there's other
intelligent life on that now there is
these kind of expanses it's not clear to
me that whatever intelligence we have or
someone else has we're gonna be able to
expand those distances in any kind of
practical way so it might not be that
we'll ever interact with those folks or
if we do it'll be some kind of just
really distant communication thing you
know I don't think you know wormholes
and all these things and it was kind of
speculated not in science fiction it
doesn't necessarily think that they're
true but I think just the odds of us
being the only intelligent beings in the
universe is kind of it's crazy it's so
the hubris of that and the kind of mana
Michael kind of egotistical thought of
that is just alone is just
makes me think that's ridiculous but
also just understanding my understanding
of how science at work and evolution
works thinks this is not gonna happen
it's not we're now alone
so then the follow-up to that is do you
think we're in a simulation
oh it's simulation it's not the basis of
that bit yeah simulation theory expands
the mind to new areas of thinking not
necessarily the point is to have a
binary yes-or-no answer but just to be
able to have the conversation
you mean that we're a simulation with in
some other universe or some other kind
of situation that's a bit of a stretch
for my own like day-to-day way of
thinking I mean just because I'm an
open-minded guy and I actually
understand that you know who knows why
would we at this error of this time of
just ten thousand years of this species
trying to think about the world but but
you know by no means do we know
everything about what's going on the
universe or what's going on even in this
planet let alone what's going on there
bodies there's tons of it under answer
questions another ten thousand years
maybe we'll figure out most of it or
maybe you know maybe five hundred years
we'll you know with the accelerated
learning we have now potentially and
maybe there's beings that are million
years old and they've nailed everything
but so I'm open to that Horning a
simulation within some other kind of
environment that we just can't perceive
and can't break out of our simulation
possible infant tends to be possible but
the way I live my life is that there's
one universe we're a part of it we are
in a little corner of this galaxy which
is one galaxy of billions and that you
know there's other beings in other parts
of the universe here and other galaxies
that I have just as meaningful poignant
and kind of intense lives as we do and
that they're doing good and we're doing
good and we should all be no totally
feeling like awesome whereas room for
everybody you know let it be you know
yeah and then last question Pete what do
you think's the most beautiful thing in
the world the most beautiful thing I'd
say Justine question should pick it up
for what's now SF
New York that's interesting question you
know I mean you know a lot of people
would fall back on this but CP what's
amazing is I do ever I have a Sam I and
you met my daughter actually so we can
bring it back to the beginning of how
you talk about this thing is like and
Greg and Greg yeah my daughter's
boyfriend the idea that two people who
love each other coming together and
having sex can actually start another
life that becomes a totally different
consciousness that becomes this being
that has a hundred years of living yeah
and that is running and with all these
amazing things that how these bodies
work and it but it comes from just
literally this bebut of connection is a
pretty magical
amazing thing that even though we know a
lot of the core science of why that
happens just this idea that that happens
is just mind-blowing and to have watch
that with my own daughter and to watch
that thing kind of grew up around me you
know which is a common experience
there's nothing you know every human
being like you can be a peasant in the
middle of Africa and you've had that
exact same poignant experience is any
sophisticated you know super high tech
rich all through wealthy person has same
human experience that's a pretty amazing
thing and so that would be at least one
of my candidates yeah that's a really
good one the complexity and all the
interesting variables around love and
also procreation molding another mind
into the world yeah and also the
complications that do arise for somebody
that is more wealthy with law purses one
that there are subtle many complications
that come from that kind of yeah and
mental health in general it's so strange
Pete Lydon such a pleasure yeah it was
great being here it's good we did we've
joined forces and can kind of talk yeah
we do more of it yeah there's so much
more we are going to be solving some of
humanity's most pressing challenges
bringing together these networks of
people California being the future and
also just build the future build the
future we talk about that all the time
on the show rebirth the public
intellectual build
future let's do it together if you guys
had a good time go and share this
content with a couple people definitely
build with this don't just consume go
create go make blog post go make videos
go start companies go and innovate go do
it guys also comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to start a community
chat about things get chatting about it
subscribe thanks everybody for tuning in
join us on patreon help us kill the
content scale the impact to more people
definitely join us there we also accept
cryptocurrency links in the bio check
out Pete's work all links in the bio
thinks are on our producer/director much
love everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you